mesurer les dangers du numérique sur la
cohésion nationale et nos institutions
afin de mieux y faire face c'est
l'objectif de cette commission bronner
une commission de lutte contre l'effet
news et le complotisme lancé par
emmanuel macron ce mercredi il faut dire
qu'on a senti à plusieurs reprises
l'exaspération du chef de l'état face à
ce phénomène le problème clé pour moi
c'est l'écrasement des hiérarchies
induits par la société du commentaire
permanent le sentiment que tout se vaut
que toutes les paroles sont égales celle
de quelqu'un qui n'est pas spécialiste
mais un avis sur le virus vaut la voie
d'un scientifique ou dans un style moins
soutenu jojo avec un gilet jaune a le
même statut qu'un ministre ou un député
les gilet jaune apprécieront d'autant
que l'effet news le complotisme voire la
désinformation ne sont pas l'apanage des
gilets jaunes ou des mouvements anti
vaccin anti passe sanitaire trois
millions de vaccins ont été gelés au
moment où je vous parle et c'est la même
occasion c'est le premier score européen
mais est non et l'information était
vérifiable assez facilement sur le site
covit tracker au suivant oui beaucoup de
détournements de l'allocation de rentrée
scolaire on sait bien que enfin si on ne
si on regarde les choses en face que
parfois il ya des achats d'écrans plats
plus important mois de septembre il ya
d'autres moments donc et non encore une
fois et ce mythe vieux de près de 15 ans
plus personne ne dit écran plat
aujourd'hui ce mythe était déjà battue
en brèche par l'exécutif lui même en
2018 on essaye encore ici à la pitié
salpêtrière on a attaqué un hôpital on a
agressé son personnel soignant et on a
blessé un policier mobilisé pour le
protéger indéfectible soutien à nos
forces de l'ordre elles sont la fierté
de la république et c'est encore raté
aucune agression de soignants ce 1er mai
2010 9 mai des manifestants qui tentent
d'échapper aux gaz lacrymogènes tirés
par les forces de l'ordre d'ailleurs ce
tweet de christophe castaner deux
sénateurs communistes ont tenté de le
faire retiré en vertu de la loi anti
féhik news une loi concoctée par le
gouvernement actuel un outil déjà
supposé lutter contre la désinformation
et qui n'a pas fonctionné comme prévu
puisque le ministre a été blanchi par le
tribunal il n'aurait je cite qu'exagéré
chacun se fera son opinion on pourra
aussi revenir sur la théorie farfelue de
la création des gilet jaune par un
conseiller de donald trump la fable des
chômeurs sur indemnisés ou les
influences selon emmanuel macron de la
fachosphère de la gauchosphère et de la
rue se faire c'est vrai que ça commence
à bien faire autre complot l'origine de
l'épidémie qui aurait fuité d'un
laboratoire p4 haouran à ce sujet rudy
reichstadt directeur de conspiracy watch
et membre de la commission justement
avait une explication c'est la
conjugaison d'une très grande méfiance
et d'un profond analphabétisme une
importante partie de la population n'a
aucune conscience de son incompétence
avant on respecter davantage la parole
des experts oui sauf que cette thèse
n'est plus présentée comme si
invraisemblable bien au contraire comme
spira si watch qui a d'ailleurs publié
il ya près de quatre ans les résultats
d'un sondage sur le complotisme chez les
français une enquête à la méthodologie
contestées alors il n'est pas question
de jeter l'opprobre sur cette commission
ni sur ses intentions ou ses membres
toute tentative de rendre plus un le
paysage médiatique et les réseaux
sociaux est louable mais on espère en
revanche qu'elle restera aussi
indépendante que ce qu'annonce gérald
bronner les mécaniques du complotisme
sont complexes et la défiance envers le
gouvernement en fait partie surtout
lorsque ce gouvernement ne fait pas
preuve de l'irréprochabilité qu'on
attend de lui